kidnappers it is all right here's a
story from the new york times
fbi says michigan anti-government group
plotted to kidnap
governor gretchen whitmer authorities
charged 13 men some of whom were accused
of plotting to storm the state capitol
building and planning to start a civil
war sounds like the
boogaloo boys but i don't think it was
directly affiliated with anybody doing
boogaloo stuff
storming the state capital instigating a
civil war abducting a sitting governor
ahead of the presidential election those
were among the plots described by
federal and state officials in michigan
and thursday as they announced terrorism
conspiracy and weapons charges against
13 men
at least six of them officials said
hatched had
had hatched a detailed plan to kidnap
governor gretchen whitmer
a democrat has become a focal point of
anti-government views and anger over
chronovirus control measures
the group that planned the kidnapping
met repeatedly over the summer for
firearms training and combat drills
and practiced building explosives the
fbi said members also gathered several
times to discuss the
mission including in the basement of a
shop that was
accessible only through a trap door
under a rug wow that's pretty cool
the trap door not the weird creepy
terrorist meetings i'd like a trap door
like that'd be cool
the men spied on miss whitmer's vacation
home in august
wow and september even looking under a
highway bridge for places they could
place and detonate a bomb
to distract authorities the fbi said
they indicated that they wanted to take
miss whitmer hostage
before the election in november and one
man said they should take her to a
secure location in wisconsin for a
trial richard j trask the second an fbi
special agent said in a criminal
complaint
if their goal was to like make donald
trump lose
this is like the best plan ever mr trask
said
that one of those arrested had bought a
taser for the mission last week
and that the men had been planning to
buy explosives on wednesday
court records indicated that at least
five of the men had been arrested on
wednesday in
ipsilanti is that they pronounce it
michigan yeah it was not immediately
clear if the sixth man had been taken
into custody so the new york times
doesn't immediately say anything about
right-wing
i don't know if they go on to i don't
think they do they just say
anti-government
but immediately you're seeing all of
these like lefty personalities saying
like right-wing militias
my right wing look at this here's the
guy i mean he's got huge gauges in his
ears
which it's not really indicative of
anything but i will say it's not
necessarily like a right wing thing you
know right wingers tend to be like
stodgy suit wearing
you know or rednecks yeah i guess i
guess
you know you could see right wing gauges
and stuff i'm not trying to i'm not
trying to discriminate against people
with gauged ears or anything like that
but he's got a big anarchy flag behind
him or a big anarchy
yeah it's a flag and so uh robbie
starbuck tweeted
this is a video of brandon caserta one
of the ringleaders of the group of men
arrested for a plot where the group
planned to kidnap governor whitmer
caserta has an anarchist flag behind him
in a youtube video trashes police
he's not a republican he's an anarchist
he's what's the difference between him
and antifa if he's
anti-cop i think that a lot of the media
is being very simplistic
about politics in general i think that
the politics are a spectrum
it's not just republicans and democrats
i think this guy's probably
an anarcho-capitalist which is like a
right-leaning
what does that mean right well i don't
know that's the problem
there's still he's still they're still
pro-capitalism this dude's auntie for as
far as i'm concerned
i mean i get it he's not literally
antifa like he's not flying the
anti-fascist action flag or anything
like that but what i mean to say is
if you take a dude he's wearing all
black and says f the police and f the
government
and then you put him next to an antifa
guy they're both going to yell the same
thing at the same time
right so i get it but it's like i i
understand he could be
anarcho-capitalist
you know because we saw with a lot of
these protests where black lives matter
came out
the boogaloo boys were like we agree
with you we're on your side like the
government is bad and it's broken
they're like all right we agree
what's the what's the difference some
one of them has an american flag
mask and the other doesn't it's like how
cop block used to be
remember they were run by like all those
libertarians up in new hampshire who
were like
anti-cop but also pro-capitalism and
i i don't know yeah and caps yeah i
guess they're just anarchists
they're certainly not trump supporters
right and it's it's this is the problem
with how the media operates
there's a really clear uh distinction
for what like left wing is
right you if you say like what's far
left you have a general idea
it's antifa it's black lives matter they
all agree with each other on most of
their ideology
they agree with each other for the most
part in economics so when you say left
wing
you're referring to like one large group
of people when they say right wing
i have no idea what that means is that
like are trump supporters right wing
the alt-right or right-wing they
disagree with the trump supporters on
like almost everything
i think that there's you know
authoritarian and then more libertarian
aspects of the right i think that the
right has a lot more
um difference of opinion and different
ideas than the left does
because they don't really accept other
ideas whereas the right
will be like okay well we disagree with
you on this but we agree on this other
thing and
um i don't know i don't think this is
the kind of guy this this dude here with
the anarchist flag behind him
who's going to be hanging out with trump
supporters right and they like governor
whitmer
immediately blamed trump she was like
this is trump's fault or whatever
and i was like these people are clearly
not trump supporters like they might
have like right-wing views on economics
but they're probably very left on things
like the border
and police and they're certainly not
trump supporters
i'm so done with left and right whatever
it just doesn't mean anything
thank you i feel like that so intensely
yeah no like this idea that you know
right wing means laissez-faire
capitalist and left-wing means socialist
and it's like
okay so the alt-right isn't
laissez-faire capitalist
they're actually kind of left on policy
you know like didn't richard spencer
talk about universal healthcare and
stuff like that
yeah i think so yeah and there's and and
and then there's cernovich too because
also talked about universal healthcare
so the right it's meaningless right
and like if if we're both left-leaning
and then you go
further left i'm all of a sudden
considered right
because it's a relative function so
it's madness that doesn't mean anything
i know so left and right are like
relative to each other well definitely
if you're talking about like
this is the weird thing if you're
talking about left and right in the
traditional sense
because it came from the french
revolution you have the right which are
pro status quo traditional like
i'm sorry to interrupt you're right you
they sat in different areas of yeah so
yeah the right and the left
and the left were the revolutionaries
and the right were the keep it all the
same right
i think they were like keep it tradition
and you know and to clarify they sat
in like what was it their parliament or
whatever they're something like that i
guess the people would sit on the right
side of the the aisle yeah on the left
side of the aisle
so the general idea is when someone says
right wing are they referring to like
pro-status quo versus pro-revolution in
which case this guy's pro-revolution
so he's certainly not right yeah he
seems like a far-left
terrorist yeah the only reason they call
him right wing is because
well they can't have it on their side
can they i it's like it doesn't even
seem far left i say that and just all of
a sudden i'm like well he's but he seems
like a far right
terrorist is it just a big circle and
you just keep going to the left and then
you appear on the right and it's like
it's because there's no it's because
right wing doesn't mean anything it
really does
none of this means anything anymore well
they have in common that they both
neither
neither antifa nor these groups this
group in particular i think neither one
of them
want much of the government to be
involved like these guys i think went to
the
open it up rally or whatever like they
were very very just
broadly anti-government i think that's
something that you could look at more
than even right or left
to determine where somebody's going to
fall along that side
i don't know where what that would be
considered like the amount of control
the government has over you oh dude
you know what man i i understand this
anger
over tyranny and abusive power
gretchen whitmer the supreme court ruled
against her and they said that you know
your lockdown's unconstitutional and she
said sound i'm gonna do it anyway
and she said that she's gonna wait out
21 days which is the like allotted time
and then she's going to find other means
to enforce her unconstitutional edict
now you're going to love this one she
said
just last week the president of the
united states stood before the american
people and refused to condemn white
supremacists
and hate groups like these two michigan
militia groups
ms whitmer said there's no indication in
the court documents that any of the men
were inspired by the president
but miss miss whitmer said extremists
had heard the president's words not as a
rebuke
but as a rallying cry as a call to
action i didn't realize that trump who
has routinely condemned anarchists
and said the violent anarchists must be
arrested was inspiring them gretchen
that's wonderful
that's the politics that we get he's
been extremely outspoken about
anarchists i mean
right it's she's a joke i can't deal
with her at all
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live
monday through friday at 8 p.m so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for
free if you want to listen to us there
thanks for hanging out
and we will see you all next time
you